il connaît chaque trait de brad pitt
mandela ou encore franck dubosc depuis
vingt ans stéphane barret sculpteur pour
le célèbre musée grévin
après une carrière à paris ce maître de
l'hyperréalisme installé son atelier à
tour lucas chopin a posé sa caméra au
milieu de dizaines de visages de
célébrité c'est visage vous dit sans
doute quelque chose
pourtant nous ne sommes pas à cannes
mais dans l'atelier de stéphane barret à
tour à 56 ans il est l'un des trois
sculpteurs hyperréaliste du musée grévin
à paris
je me suis lancé dans l'hyperréalisme un
peu par hasard puisque quand j'ai fait
le test grévin quand on m'a dit est ce
que tu as déjà fait de libéralisme qui
dit oui alors que je n'avais jamais fait
jong hong un peu un un faussaire voilà
j'essaie de de dupliquer au mieux tous
les personnages ou nous tous les animaux
depuis l'an 2000 il a réalisé plus de 50
buts pour le musée parisien
il travaille en étroite collaboration
avec les artistes mais aussi à partir de
scanner de photos très détaillée en
moins de cinq semaines stéphane barret
est capable d'achever une sculpture
extrêmement réaliste à l'aide d'une pâte
à modeler qu'ils ne sachent pas mais
aussi d'outil de sa fabrication
installé depuis janvier rue des landes à
tour il travaille en parallèle sur ses
créations personnelles des hommes et des
femmes nus à billets seulement de coiffe
extravagantes
je veux créer un certain trouble par
rapport à ces à ses créations
littéraires et à liste et puis par
exemple pour le musée grévin
arrivé à à duper la personne en leur
disant voilà bah non c'est c'est pas le
vrai c'est c'est la fausse personne
c'est la fausse personnalité stéphane
barret encore de nombreux projets à tour
à terme il aimerait dédié une partie de
son atelier à l'exposition d'artistes
variés